people often ask me does my white change
over time and the answer is no you only
have one y in one way only and it is the
same way you have for your whole life
whether it's a person or an organization
that Y is basically an origin story it's
basically where you come from your Y is
is who you are it comes from the lessons
you've learned and the experiences you
had growing up and the rest of your life
simply provides opportunities to either
live in balance
or out of balance but the Y cannot
change you are who you are that's why
this understanding the Y is such a
powerful thing because once you
understand deeply what drives you the
opportunity is then to put yourself in
positions of strength and things that
will inspire you